this is an orate hurricane
grp burs at the line shoots left pass Stop Corpus
Salo losing in Vancouver right after the game at
a players only meeting on brenor has called
out the team Jordan Stall Sebastian aov all
the way in along the way and it's not been
pretty after losses in Winnipeg being blown
out at Edmonton losing narrowly in Calgary
and then letting one slip away in Vancouver
W they feel like all the lip Services said
it's all about getting it done now the truck
shoots blocker stopped by poov from the line
that one tipped in toov a piece and it ends
up Mason well and tereno comes back to help out
Gams Rec cover PCO swung to the line his shot is
blocked out in front they had both forwards get
into the lane that's determination and they got
a little spit tap on the bench it was first it
was Parker Kelly and then it was n get getting
in front of those pucks as the D are very active
and like to throw everything towards the net Jus
savs at the line his Slap Shot unloaded off a
shin pad darts into the corner Ottawa all over
the canes North centering K crashing k caught
down work back to the line rot tipped in nice
score nice tip in front and Norris has got the
sends on the board it's all about pressure off
the four check turning tucks over aggressively
kept in now it's down low and you see Josh
Norris throw it towards the net the Chuck and
martinuk go sliding into the post ketov never
gets set after he's got a player right in his
crease and there's the battle in front Chuck
mirring the puck supporting the play up the wall
now he works to the front of the net there's the
physical battle and Maru runs right into the
arm of kachuck down slide and then and Cami
comes down with it around CH zo helped out his
deep partner filter back to the middle Ottawa
finding their stride but turned around quickly
bami drps the ter back to toam he shoots off
the post struck iron on the blocker side of
corus Salo quickly Carolina with transition
in the neutral zone that's all about managing
the puck and being strong on your stick Tim
stutler was pickpocketed and they went back
3-2 and it ended up costing them a chance
against C the shot tring to leave it for
giru right at top of that senator's logo
orof stretches it out AO and shoots left St by
couro who pushed out to take away the room sers
from the line was shade for a moment s have some
speed moving to the the middle Waters open up and
a Glock stopped by coach heck Hub coming over
at the last moment to Rob Matthew Joseph this
is a fantastic save by ketov and what a pass by
Ridley Greg to send Joseph in alone it's try to
take advantage stla two on one with tereno stla
coming in looks back holds up plays it across
and out of what Tero denight on the doorstep
offer back hand coov lost the stick and made the
save unbelievable save by ketov and a penalty
coming AR decides to pull shoot go back to the
autoa bench Kan start up in their own Zone
scet pass beatss everybody though in with
the back hand and another Docker able to get
in the way of that one back at the line Burns
disrupted doing his best just to clear could not
get it out Jes working across and they bury NIS
on the one timer with a power play goal draws
it even in the first n just back to the point
bouncing Pock therea Char TR both pressing but a
saucer pass and then a seam play and nus gets a
avilable onetime no chance for cor pasalo on that
play as it goes from left to right but it's two
quick passes in the back of the net and we have
a tie game kette kep that one out for Docker Pi
pocket H service H shot is denied only the goal
of the game from the Hurricanes arve this way
with nous recording a power play marker in
the first D'Angelo sends it across gets it
back oh she scores Sebastian AO breaks out of a
four game pointless streak and he's got a power
play goal to give the canes a lead when the
draw they start moving the puck around at the
Blue Line D'Angelo looking for options and
then there's Jarvis you see him at the last
second as AO looking for the lane Jarvis gets
out of the way corpo trying to find a lane he's
looking left AO goes right blocker side and
a penalty off of a PO exchange reversus orop
is there as Nason breaking through the middle
orop trying again blast and out but Sanderson
looked like he was going to cut it down now
two on0 Jarvis played it over back to Jarvis
scores the hurricanes have found their stride
and Jarvis finds a way to beat Corpus Salo
battle along the wall sanderson's there B's there
it's a change with ch and the late change doesn't
jump so it's Sanderson who's chasing the puck
back no CH changes and it's the late jump they
branched him to try and get back into the play
and it's too late with Baptist in at Center turn
the corter back hander that would have been
a highlight real Beauty now b w double patch
that kick save I never seen that as coach K cup
pulls up a remarkable save Billy ran for two patch
Stacks Kans going to draw in Casi now AO back
to pesi nearly found him heading to the net St
in coverage able to get back to his Mark oh some
room scores a TW goal three points second period
for Sebastian AO just too much time and space for
him to walk off the the wall he does a good job
of little curl back play by pesi now watch here
it's a one-on-one situation he just steps right
down the middle we just talked about the middle
of the ice giving up when NES on the last play
gets the opportunity while same situation as
well steps on the inside he gets a step on Tim
stla he's on a strong side on his forehand and
he's able to pick just inside the post on the
Block the other way SP move on the outside of
scord NIS and scord holds his ground defensively
two on one STS on the right K on the left the K
stop on the S on the line how did that not work
shot I think protto threw a
stick on was has been awarded
a penalty shot for the goenda
his stick he came across Brady kachuck a
penalty shot to grab momentum against p
kov kachu in quickly T by kov who just PS out the
chucka speed's going to take it to the back end
and there's the the Poke check and the captain
comes goes hard into the boards comes right
back it has a few words for the
goenda and makes the save mled one wide theay
call coming against AA if the buzzer doesn't beat
them and Carolina will get back into the
wind column with a 4-1 victory over Ottawa